official details on the new Mass Effect
game are scarce but it seems fans may
have figured out the name of the
protagonist the Mass Effect subreddit
has been abuzz with theories since a
sharp eye that belongs to reddit user
Ben Ali odo caught a dog tag on the left
side of the screen 44 seconds into the
n7 day 2015 trailer the dog tag looks
like it reads writer with a why or an
eye according to Ben óleo de the user
also mentioned that the protagonist
could be named after Sally Ride the
first American woman in space this would
fit with the naming of the original
trilogy's protagonist who is named
Shepherd after the first American man in
space alan shepard in addition to the
possible coincidence when a fan asks
Bioware Montreal studio director Deanna
Troi if they could change the song to
proper music that fits the Mass Effect
universe wrote applied in a tweet no
sorry because there are very good
reasons for that choice of song for the
trailer that should become clear later
on what we know for sure is that we
won't be seeing any familiar faces in
Andromeda including the original
protagonist Commander Shepard which
Bioware senior development director
Chris Flynn has asked fans to be
open-minded about Mass Effect Andromeda
will be the fourth main game and biola
science fiction role-playing series and
is set for a holidays 2016 release